[Music]
and this brings back so many memories
right school's out it's evening time and
it's time for Jean Ami
oh you mean the greatest lineup of
animation ever all right let's get this
party started
where are you kids keep it down some of
us have actual work to do around there
but critic we're watching tanami
night don't care what your kids are into
nowadays just turn that down Bob I turn
you down what does that even mean I
don't care I ball turn it down that's
better
work bills adult a wait I don't get it
isn't this an episode on Toonami well it
was just past his age range so so he
doesn't know the impact it had on so
many people nah man he's gotten old he's
become one of them and a jolt well for
someone who talks about nostalgia so
much he should be educated about it yeah
he's too close-minded no it is our duty
to teach him about the awesomeness of
Toonami
[Music]
yeah Phoebe tippet how many governors
hey critic Oh what did your phone's
break hey you Millennials dude your
calculators a phone I know what I said
what I say you were asking what we
wanted yeah that we know that Toonami
was a little bit past your time but you
really should understand the impact that
it had on kids to tell more epic story
the only thing appointed people my age
is knowing how much people your age suck
now get out of here while I eat my goon
see he's too old just let him hate
everything no critic it's your duty to
represent these timeless shows I've made
an impact on a generation how dare you
boy and if we're gonna get you into this
we're gonna do it the right way
what's up - not me faithful Tom wait you
know tom is pretty bad watch a little -
Dom Mia it's time to kick ass where
there was none and inviting those who
doubt the awesomes no this is both
humbug poppycock
come on critic it's time for you to see
the light
oh okay in 1997 the then relatively new
Cartoon Network ran a weekday series of
shows called tuna this wasn't their 100%
family-friendly programming but it
wasn't their late-night grown-up Adult
Swim programming either there was
somewhere in between they mostly focused
on series with a lot of action slightly
to extremely mature themes and usually
have a leaning towards a Japanese style
of animation in fact many of the shows
were imports from Japan introducing a
whole new generation to classic anime
that while available in America didn't
have nearly the same following until
Toonami came along the problem is while
I was aware of its existence though I
saw only bits of it at a time I didn't
really grow up with Toonami to fully
reflect on what it meant to so many
people so we're gonna go through all the
shows that left the biggest impact on us
now keep in mind we didn't grow up with
every show on Toonami so some parts will
be missing we're just gonna hit the ones
that influenced us the most for better
or worse I'm Malcolm so let's dive right
into it
despite Tom being the best-known host
tzunami actually started off with multi
from space ghost coast to coast
introducing every show you are about to
see why does that show sound familiar
space Batman with no years he's not
brand new superstar
though he wasn't Tom he was still a
pretty cool host still keeping the
laid-back low-key tone to offset the
extreme soundtrack an action that often
played alongside him
we call the superfriends one of the
first shows to start off tsunami was a
collection of old superhero store it's
called cartoon roulette I'm familiar
with a grand way to start this off
mm-hmm
this was a send-up of all the classic
superhero cartoons of old it ranged from
the groundbreaking Fleischer Superman
serials from the 40s
the enjoyably cheesy hanna-barbera
shorts of the 60s to the Superfriends
show in the 70s when the Justice League
fought side by side with Wonder dog into
human perms and bell-bottoms I can see
why this tsunami was so popular
honestly it was more of a kind gesture
than hit programming this was a fun way
of showing how far superhero shows have
come as the story style and characters
were often pretty laughably bad compared
to modern day series it was the
equivalent of showing the Adam West
Batman before the Dark Knight it was
just interesting to see how far we've
come regardless it was still cool to see
the history of many of these icons and
animation and some of them like the
Fleischer cartoons still have amazing
animation that would inspire many
classic cartoons of the future so while
hilariously dated it was also neat to
see what some of the great superhero
shows we've grown to love today were
inspired by yeah don't listen to wonder
dog I'm sure Captain Caveman will need a
sidekick soon but not every show had
dated animation some was cutting-edge
like the first fully computer animated
TV show reboot
ever wanted to see Canada's version of
wreck-it Ralph it's got to be less scary
than their PSAs reboots the game-changer
about changing games
[Music]
while the show ran in syndication reboot
arguably got its biggest following on
Toonami even to the final season
premiering on it the gist is a computer
system city known as mainframe
constantly under attack from the viruses
megabyte and hexadecimal it's up to the
Guardian program Bob with his friends
Enzo and dot matrix they catch on rivers
I'll be quiet
to defend mainframe from the viruses and
GameCubes no not those game tubes unless
batman dark tomorrow is ever sent into
the city by the user precise reboot was
a really fun and unique show it was the
same production company mainframe
entertainment that also produced Beast
Wars transforms this show was
imaginative interesting and filled with
some very memorable characters even
though they look like one more man eat
the rock from Mummy Returns you don't
get it man and you weren't there what
you didn't care yeah okay which is one
that it may not look as impressive all
these years later but the design style
actually worked for the show and when
you consider the time period it's
definitely a technical achievement how
dare you interrupt me when I'm putting
on my face
unfortunately reboot ended on an
unresolved cliffhanger and there hasn't
been much talk about finishing the story
in the year since there was a
reimagining released recently called
reboot the Guardian code but the less
said about that the better next though
it started off a bit more kid-friendly
it got more intense and adult as the
show went on leaving many of us with a
show that while dated-looking was still
stylized groundbreaking and gave us some
cool adventures it ironically doesn't
need a reboot to be remembered fine
[Music]
but as mentioned before anime played a
big part in tsunamis lineup and one of
animes biggest names is Sailor Moon oh
no need I've covered this before but I
can cover it correctly without your
crime-fighting miniskirts and don't trip
on your hair extensions Sailor Moon is
rocking the planets
the 90s were all about girl power and
dunkaroos
it was a movement and nothing to find
that more than Sailor Moon Sailor Moon
follows The Adventures of Serina a
teenager who discovers that she has the
ability to transform into a magical
Sailor Scout from the Moon Kingdom she
later discovers that there are four
other girls who also have these powers
and together they form a team that must
fight the powers of the night covers to
protect Earth oh please say the leader
of the naked person looks like this
kinda each scout is named after the
planets Sailor Mercury Mars Jupiter
Venus and of course moon moon is not a
planet
it's a moon moon
[Applause]
eventually they'd be joined by others
including Neptune Uranus and Pluto just
to name a few
the ladies kick butt and took names in
the name of the moon which is not a
planet and is still one of the
longest-running magical girl anime
zephyr it had worldwide appeal to girls
women and even boys invent Sailor Moon
was a wonderful show that was
action-packed sweet and cute it
showcased strong female friendships with
humor romance and adventure in America
is actually first shown on two other
networks before it took hold on Toonami
in 1998 it was part of the lineup for
the next three years being a staple in
its early identity seasons 3 & 4 were
originally aired on Toonami a little bit
more unedited than the original two
seasons all three movies were also shown
on Toonami season five of the series was
never aired on television as the
contract expired in 2003 and has never
been renewed or shown on American
television since why is that well this
is just a theory but season 5 starred
three new Sailor Scouts dubbed the
Sailor star lights who were a men at
least pretending to be while on earth
that transformed into women when they
took their powered form I'm guessing
that something 2001 probably wasn't
ready for oh come on they may say Leah
rain this and Neptune cousins has to
have lesbians resulting in it seems so
long ago my first kiss like it was
yesterday
[Applause]
kids hearing the term kissing cousins
for the first time though there were
certainly action shows that had girls in
them the cast's were usually
male-dominated so it's nice that Toonami
not only had a show that was female
dominated but was also funny imaginative
and incredibly entertaining proving the
lasting power of the moon again not a
planet
neither is Pluto that just proves my
point war is not going away anytime soon
I know Sailor Moon was a real big hit
anime and tsunami but it was another one
that was an even bigger hit I think was
cold center screaming volume two over
nine thousand one of the most popular
animes of all time is flying right at
Dragon Ball Z what can be said about
Dragon Ball Z that hasn't already been
said there are a couple of animes that
immediately spring to mind when you hear
the word Dragon Ball Z was definitely
one of them we follow the story of Goku
which is loosely based on Journey to the
West on steroids this is actually the
sequel to the show Dragon Ball in which
our hero Goku tried to collect powerful
Dragon Balls in order to summon a dragon
to grant him and his friends wishes
Dragon Ball somewhat confusingly
wouldn't air on Toonami until after
Dragon Ball Z was shown but thankfully
you can follow Dragon Ball Z fine even
if you haven't seen the original Dragon
Ball this show had everything explosive
battles wacky situational comedy and
unforgettable iconic characters it still
maintains some of the characters and
worlds is the original Dragon Ball but
adds more Goku is now grown up he
discovers that he's actually part of a
race called the sands from his brother
Raddatz but had a head injury shortly
after his arrival and totally forgot his
mission of destruction of dominance so
kind of like Iron Giant meets a
screaming good absolutely nothing like
that but if it helps you sure Goku
refuses to join Raddatz and fighting
ensues the lore of the series was
massively expanded over its 291 episode
run the next generation is also
introduced as Goku becomes a father his
sons Gohan and Goten had varying sized
roles as the series progressed DBZ put
anime on the map for most of the Western
world while it had some syndication on
various channels Toonami have become the
primary hub to broadcast the show with a
chilling 61 million viewership rating
for every new episode
it ran four years on the program block
even after its initial run the show was
redubbed re-edited and reached shown it
really connected with people in a
massive way Toonami had never seen
before in his programming it was
marketed to a large age range focusing
on the action and humor of the show it
has often been imitated and parodied
especially when people want to go super
saiyan we couldn't get enough of it the
fights the powers the characters the
stories it was endlessly entertaining
and this show's legacy has not slowed
down it became super quotable from
characters spouting quippy one-liners to
shouting their signature moves before
doing them in it's over nine it was very
monster of the week but it's
entertainment value came from the
over-the-top adventures the characters
would go on maybe the most humorous
thing about Toonami airing DBZ was how
ridiculous the censorship sometimes was
Funimation and American sensors went
infamously overboard with how much they
wanted to cut down on some of the
violence blood and crude humour of the
original Japanese version everything
from changing translations to
hilariously obvious visual additions
were apparent through its first run on
tsunami I remember the last time I had a
frosty mug of water
remember when killing meant sending you
to another dimension or the home for
infinite losers well did they really
think we couldn't take hearing the word
hell we just watched someone get their
entire body cut in half the uncut
episodes were later released but the
ridiculous attempts at sanitizing DBZ is
a big part of its initial identity in
the u.s. regardless the concept may be
simplistic but if anything Dragon Ball
is a story about friendship and how you
can find allies in unexpected places
even old enemies eventually become
allies to take on even greater
challenges while there's certainly
people who just see it a screen porn and
yeah I can see why when you really sit
down and watch it you can see how much
of an epic story they can tell with
simple yet likeable and relatable
characters Dragon Ball Z has had a
lasting impression around the world
becoming a template for shown in action
series for the future the show defined
the late 90s and early 2000s for
millions of kids and tsunami owes a
giant chunk of its popularity at the
time to the epicness that is Dragonball
Z no come on it's nowhere near the
impact of real Adventures of Johnny
Quest had I just want to talk about
something I know somewhere in between
the sixties where everything was weirdly
shadowed and nowadays where Tom and
Jerry are invited on missions Jonny
Quest a surprisingly decent show
based on the campy spy cartoon from the
60s hanna-barbera gave Johnny Quest a
total upgrade including better animation
more complex stories and characters and
high-tech ish CGI yeah what were you
saying about the CGI on reboot again it
was a long time ago things change the CG
is cleverly used just one they need to
enter the virtual world
the rest of the show is hand-drawn and
while still kid-friendly and a bit more
of a mature edge to it bandit come on
bandit over here
okay I said a bit it could be kind of
silly but it's Jonny Quest it's kind of
expected with weird elements like the
quest virtual worlds Hutchy now having
psychic powers you know that old Indian
cliche and like I said giving the dog
still a prominent role you could tell it
didn't want to totally lose its corny
roots it only had two seasons and never
rose that high in the ratings but
Toonami still gave its reruns a home
well it's nothing great it's a totally
serviceable cartoon a series of
adventures to entertain you for a bit
probably be forgotten in the near future
so why are we talking about it again
then because this intro is amazing
okay that was worth talking about yeah
I'm so glad Everett that off in summer
of 1999 it was decided Multi would be
scrapped from hosting duties and rather
than pick an already existing character
they made one from scratch Tom finally
entered the picture looking like
Bomberman if he was pregnant he was
voiced by Steve bloom and the following
year was given a look that reflected the
fact that he was voiced by Steve bloom
actually he was first voiced by Sandy
Strait I guess he just wasn't clearly
knit another tsunami also extended its
run time by an additional hour showing
as popularity was growing they also
added reruns of classic shows like
Batman and Superman but they don't
quench my fantasy to be chased by five
alien women who all had the hots for me
no one's gonna stare at me
we're used to it at this point Tom being
played over and over he has a condition
it's called limited Toonami budgets yeah
he's very sensitive about it we tried to
bring it up I'm sorry
I'll pretend I didn't hear that anywho
get your digital bikinis ready because
we're making a PG show out of something
that was clearly and to be in our
Tenchi Muyo was a harem anime with
situational comedy that escalates it too
surreal space fantasy adventure on a
whim it focused around 10g a 17 year old
boy who releases a space pirate named
ryuko it's time to conquer that'd be a
very different show fit with that angle
you sure it isn't over time for other
women who are strange energetic and did
I mention hot as hell it's an anime you
don't need to arrive at 10 she's home
and constantly try to get in his pants
Oh family big kick you don't know the
half of it or maybe you only know the
half of it as all the nudity was
constantly covered up on the show as
well as all the swearing being read of
and the blood being edited out oh it's
like that HBO family cut of a Clockwork
Orange that was me despite it not having
the intended adult edge to it Tenchi
Muyo was still fun fanservice see and
something you desperately scour the
video store to find unedited versions of
later - Nami would release other Tenchi
properties including tenshi and Tokyo
and Tenchi universe and while they
certainly left their mark on their fans
as well Tenchi Muyo is the one that
tsunami fans remember introducing them
to a situational problem none of them
ever had but they so wish they did
what do you think that got heavily
censored wait until you see this next
one look at what it used to be sugar
spice and everything kick-ass The
Powerpuff Girls are gonna save the day
with their wide eyes of justice to this
day my favorite lady group though it
already had a huge following on Cartoon
Network's segment called cartoon
cartoons they were badass enough to air
on tsunami as well honestly it always
makes too much sense though not an anime
you can tell it was heavily inspired /
heavily satirizing that style and seeing
how tsunami was neck deep in anime and
only figured to have a show that was
both an homage and a parody of it as
well
created by professor utonium what's here
Professor X ology he accidentally
creates the three super girls as you do
one night in the lab blossom is the
leader bubbles is the soft kind one and
Buttercup is our tough ball of eggs to
their credit they stick to these
personality tropes way better and more
consistently than some girl gangs mama
mia anyone no thanks the show is full of
fun dialogue a great art style and
characters that were new and creative
the villains especially stand out
creepy him looked different than any
other animated character I'd ever seen
the amoeba boys sedusa Mojo Jojo a
classic not to mention the mayor of
Townsville calling all these
kindergartners every day to help save
the city
those five year olds have some major
political clout not letting little kids
fight our battles anymore
what
the violence on the show is also
something not seen in children shows
anymore being both surprisingly harsh
and extreme again a perfect fit for
tsunami even though it probably didn't
need two nominees help to get famous it
did submit them is not only funny but
badass as how proving epic fights aren't
just for the big kids well only one
thing could be more extreme than crime
fighting kindergarteners I think there's
a lot of things that can be more extreme
a show from the guy who made Dexter's
Lab sentences full of disappointments
sharpen your swords and type your man
mine's Samurai Jack is in the house who
the shape-shifting master of Darkness
unleashed an unspeakable evil but a
foolish samurai warrior wielding a magic
sword stepped forth to oppose him before
the final blow was struck he tore open a
portal in time and flung the samurai
into the future we are whose evil is law
now the samurai seeks to return to the
past and undo the future that is ah oh
did you just repeat the show's intro I'm
sorry do you have a better way of
explaining the premise that's why I
thought now he's got to get back back to
the past
samurai come on Samurai Jack is nothing
short of amazing creator genndy
tartakovsky went from comedy to intense
action comedy while hardly having to
change his look at all the show was
packed to the brim with style and
substance Jack was a near-perfect
protagonist and his never-ending crusade
to return to the past to save the future
was as compelling a journey as I've seen
in almost any other animated show is he
supposed to look like professor utonium
as a ninja scroll character no he's
supposed to look like a black guy voices
I have so many questions
the late great Mako hosts the sinister
aku and could be as funny as he was
threatening I'd like to place an order
delivery 30 minutes oh it's the mix of
talent from loud hilarity to quiet
character studies resulted in a truly
unique piece of cartoon history it
originally aired from 2001 to 2004 but
didn't regularly start appearing on
Toonami until 2008 in 2017 the show was
revived for a fifth and final season
that was meant to finally wrap up Jack's
story this time the new episodes debuted
on the Toonami block and were noticeably
more adult in some ways I could talk
about this show for hours but if you
want more in-depth thoughts I did a top
5 video on the best episodes right here
on channel awesome and also reviewed
every episode of the final season on my
personal channel if you've never seen
Samurai Jack you're missing out on one
of if not the best original series
Cartoon Network ever produced well
that's cool I thought a big part tsunami
was anime not like anime where's all the
Japanese fighting a giant robots oh you
mean like no nothing like that
oh well too bad it's the series that
launched a thousand series which an
anime is still pretty funny time to
bring in the Gundam
if you've ever wanted to watch angsty
beautiful teen voice fight and giant
robots you mean there's people who don't
then boy have I got a show for you
Gundam Wing follows the story of five
teenagers who were selected to be a part
of operation meteor in which they were
sent to earth and high-powered mobile
suits called Gundams to seek revenge on
a political organization called oz
please tell me this is just the Japanese
version of The Wizard of Oz the guys are
all vaguely named after numbers there
was hero Yui
duo Maxwell trowa Barton catcher Barbra
winner and changwu Fay sound complicated
and little convoluted you bet it is it
was the perfect mix of angst giant robot
battles and political intrigue
personally I was captured by it because
it was something that I had never seen
before the show sees the hearts and
attention of Americans when it debuted
in 2000 it was top-rated and stayed that
way for a while part of the appeal was
the boys they were like a murdering
badass boyband each of their own
personality types hero was the brooding
deep loner duo was the wisecracking
jokester Capra was the kind gentle one
Charl was quiet thoughtful and mu Fey
was well super righteous I guess Scary
Spice was the wild card please those
clearly Baby Spice Gundam Wing was
actually much more successful in America
than in Japan where was originally
released in 1995 it introduced American
audiences to the extremely popular
Gundam franchise Toonami tried to
capitalize on the interest by showing
other shows in the series including the
original Mobile Suit Gundam but nothing
quite stuck as much as wing dick
although it did create a generation of
people like me who have spent literally
hundreds of dollars on plastic models of
robots how did you fit all those in your
pocket modern anime is in America oh I
do have thanks to gonna win it was aired
with none of them
of the characters or music change from
the original Japanese it was also the
first unedited anime ever run on Cartoon
Network as a part of tsunami after dark
I always remember staying up until
midnight to watch these unedited
episodes where the characters said death
and swore and had blood in a battle yeah
the early two-thousands were a more
innocent time oh I don't know it gave us
this staying true to its source altering
little and giving their all in every
frame Gundam told a compelling story
with compelling characters not
surprisingly keeping us compelled well I
like my big robot enemies to constantly
rip off Batman you mean you actually saw
let it go it's show time how about that
a tsunami anime The Critic is seen I
think you just thought James Bond joint
Power Rangers or something
Rico is like a collection of five
different sci-fi shows that don't go
together yet somehow they really don't
go together but the elements they're
combining aren't still pretty damn cool
a man named Roger Smith wakes up
realizing his memory has been erased as
it so happens everyone's memories around
him have been erased too
rather than oh look for answers everyone
stays in their futuristic cities were
the rich are encased in giant bubbles
and the poor are left to decay in the
real world you said this was science
fiction androids are a big part in the
city's environment and one name are
dorothy is created as a decoy for a real
kidnapped girl but since the girl is
never found and the Android has nowhere
to go
she stays with Roger and his Butler
trying to stop wrongdoings and if
there's time figure out what happened -
everybody's memories oh and for no
reason at all
Jonny robots why because robots yeah on
one level it's a monster the weak show
on another it's a crime-fighting show on
another it's a social commentary show on
another it's a funny buddy show and on
another it's Blade Runner it's far too
many elements to go together but they're
very cool elements to go together and
the style with them both the characters
and the designs reflect that our Dorothy
is one of the great deadpan characters
she has little to no emotion as strong
as hell and drives Roger crazy with a
robotic preciseness it's like if Daria
was the Terminator
you mean Dorothy is going to be living
with us it's not because I want to do I
have to make you get out you may try but
I'm doubtful that a mere human would
have the strength you know a show is
working when the opposite version of the
character is presented and legitimately
creepy just seeing her smile is like
when Wednesday Adam smiles it's kind of
terrifying
[Music]
the show sadly didn't do very well in
Japan meaning they had to stop at 13
episodes even though they want to do 13
more well Toonami enjoyed it so much
they co-produced the rest of the
episodes to finish it out there were
just too many people who wanted to know
what was gonna happen next
does it work as a whole I suppose not it
is too many different elements coming
together but those elements are so
memorable and awesome that I can't see
myself ever forgetting them they may
have had a short run but it's one of the
most memorable short runs an anime could
ever have hmm needs more hamsters it's
an taro time cushy cushy ticky ticky
move to top just say that
[Music]
of course it's Hamtaro hem taro was
unbelievably goddamn cute if you were
having a bad day watching this anime
about hamsters learning the value of
teamwork would easily turn your frown
upside down
oh he fights crime in the middle of the
night nope
he goes outside makes new friends
sometimes they play in the backyard
where they say the magic words and turn
into ninjas no he just tries to make his
owner happy a ten year old girl named
Laura and Laura is a demon hunter no
she's just a kid that enjoys playing
with Hamtaro and the ham hams
hey I'm hams Gees critic you're acting
like this isn't a perfect fit for
Toonami
yes of course amongst all the fighting
and the bloodshed in the intense action
ham Taro's the most badass of them all
it's Hamtaro man taro my sunflower seed
is gone this was on Toonami
yes this is pointless you know some
people just don't understand the epic
weights of an taro I think wait man you
either get whammed hurry you don't get
Hamtaro okay
guess I don't get hem taro I'm
embarrassed for all of us let's just
move on to something a little bit more
laid-back
and subdued Justice League huh yeah what
before the DCU it was whatever that
movie was there was a Justice League
that knew how to give
what they want
Justice League is such a quality show
the animation is excellent and
consistent the storylines are engaging
and exciting not dumbing things down for
a younger audience but bringing every
age along for the ride and the chemistry
between the main core superhero group is
my favorite in all of DC adaptations
also let's be honest having Martian
Manhunter and Hawkgirl part of the main
group ruled you mean it's a Harvey
Birdman crossover I said hot girl not
bird girl Oh
Justice League had mostly two-part
episode z' while Justice League
Unlimited the show that came directly
after two seasons of Justice League
dropped that format and added even more
characters though I guess it was okay if
that meant getting the most awesome
punch Superman has ever thrown
I want to marry that punch even in
Justice League though the lesser-known
character cameos could stack up to the
dozens or even hundreds they tackled
some cool storylines like Superman dying
the Legion of Doom assembling and the
love story between Hawkgirl and Green
Lantern also the cast of Teen Titans
came in and voiced the Royal Flush gang
hired by the Joker to fight the league
and it was awesome that is the weirdest
sentence I have ever heard you utter you
should hear me when I'm sober there's so
many people wanting that perfect Justice
League adaptation I say we already got
it it had many adult moments but never
lost sight of that childlike wonderment
it was action-packed but smart
aggressive but sensitive followed the
comics but also stood as their own thing
I much rather take this Batman and
Superman fighting than this Batman and
Superman fighting any day
it's drapes though with Dragonball Z
being such a big hit you think they run
more Dragon Ball shows Walter only with
every Canyon destroying step forward you
take a Canyon destroying step back
Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball GT will
start and continue the Dragon Ball
legacy Dragon Ball was I guess in
tsunamis order the prequel to their hit
show Dragon Ball Z it followed a boy
with the tail named Goku and his new
friend Bulma on their quest to collect
the seven mystical Dragon Balls
when all seven are brought together the
eternal dragon Shenron appears granting
his summoner one wish
oh please everybody who saw Dragonball
Evolution knows that see that's what
happens when you mention that movie
along the way Goku makes new friends
enemies is trained further in the
martial arts fights in tournaments and
takes on a whole army this anime was
released in Japan in 1986 but only
started airing on Toonami in 2001
therefore a lot of kids saw Dragon Ball
after already being exposed to the much
more action-oriented in serious second
series Dragon Ball had plenty of action
but it was a much lighter show it was
more comedic and goofy I'll admit it was
a bit jarring back then at the height of
DB Z's popularity to see something so
different that involved the same
characters I felt they already knew very
well it wasn't until I was older that I
appreciated the series for what it was
and truly enjoyed it Dragon Ball will
forever be important to the history of
anime and animation in general it's
filled with great storytelling adventure
action and its trademark pervy comedy
you let me have your Dragon Ball and
I'll let you have a little peek what do
I care about seeing your dirty old Fanny
I feel like a lot of people watching now
should be asking that Dragon Ball GT
takes place several years after the end
of the scene it follows Goku being
transformed back into a child by the
Black Star Dragon Balls with trunks and
his granddaughter pan he has to travel
the galaxy to find them so he can be
transformed back into his adult state
this series is notable for it not being
based on a manga and having limited
involvement from Dragonball creator
Akira Toriyama
this is a good thing or bad thing this
is absolutely the black sheep of the
Dragonball family it only lasted 64
episodes and failed to connect with its
audience like DBZ did when Dragonball Z
was still airing I remember hearing so
much about GT magazines internet
articles rumors about what was going to
happen on the show were present quite a
bit among the fanbase there was almost
this mystique surrounding when they
finally aired it in 2003 I knew right
away this wasn't going to be what I had
come to expect yes this is happening
that crappy intro was simultaneously the
dumbest and most disappointing thing I
had ever heard say what you will about
DB Z's American score by Bruce Falconer
but I grew up loving most of it and his
presence was sorely missed in DB GT the
American music was terrible and that was
the least of this show's problems I
think the plan was to take the Dragon
Ball saga back to its roots by turning
Goku into a kid again but it did not
work to complicate matters
Funimation edited together chunks of the
first 16 episodes as a 1 episode Toonami
premiere well that's almost as stupid as
telling an entire season of a show and a
movie almost these were later released
as the lost episodes as Funimation was
concerned about the big tonal shift GT
made from Z it remains a gigantic
letdown but that was far from the end of
Dragon Ball content as previously stated
the popularity of Dragon Ball is doing
just fine nowadays and it doesn't look
to be ending anytime soon
[Music]
and it doesn't look like two nominees
popularity was gonna end anytime soon
either with all these epics shows that
they're constantly putting out I can't
wait to see what tsunami it would do
next summer you learn just how cool it
is to be part of the Guzzi game what the
hell was that no seriously what was that
[Applause]
tanaami eventually started what they
called their midnight run meaning
because the shows were shown later they
could get away with more blood gore and
smell more adult stuff they couldn't get
away with in prime time
so most school ad shows would find
themselves working their way into the
Tanami lineup including GI Joe Voltron
he-man and Thundercats and the nice
thing about these reruns is some of them
spawned some pretty decent reboots hey I
didn't miss the cake did I yeah like I
said pretty decent Thundercats for
example got a completely new show trying
to update the original material with a
more mature storyline and characters and
give the animation more of an avatar the
last airbender look it was a decent
attempt but it never caught on I think
the reason is it made the characters a
little too young a lot of us like
Thundercats because it was watching
grown men and women kick ass with the
kids as the side characters it's not
that we didn't welcome more complex
stories we just wanted it with more
grown-up characters not growing up
characters I mean come on we won't hear
the Thundercats talk like this it was
just plain stupid to assume it might be
bad just what the am I talking
about I mean come on how about show that
finally gives the fans what we've always
wanted to see from these characters
[Music]
nailed it g-man was also given a
makeover tried to give it a grander and
somewhat darker tone they did a lot of
things pretty good like you Skeletor a
pretty cool backstory and made the look
of the show more focused on the
Barbarian aspect rather than the sci-fi
but it's still he-man it's still corny
silly and goes back and forth between
being really dark and gritty and being
do well he-man she's kidding right some
kind of birthday Frank I mean I guess
it's better than Dolph Lundgren getting
his ass whipped by a laser right
twizzler but no I have nothing else to
add it is definitely better than that
both this and Thundercats were valiant
attempts and honestly not bad shows on
their own but neither were the epic
reboot fans were expecting hey man did
manage to get one more season while
Thundercats sadly only got one but come
on man we're here to talk about what
Toonami is best remembered for yeah Tom
what's the next show coming up
is the summer well Tom woods different
yeah imagine one day you came home ready
to see Tom hype you up with action and
may Hammond instead you got this it
looks like the girl from Monsters Inc
got older and entrapped the monsters in
an aquarium if they tried to escape
she'll kill Bill bare-asses go back away
from the remote
this was Magoo Z Cartoon Network's
replacement for tsunami during the
weekday starting in 2004 as you can tell
it was aimed at much younger kids I
think you guys are quite ready for each
other right but what happened to to Nami
it was now only airing on Saturday
nights from 7 p.m. to 11 p.m.
fans were thrilled still even though it
was only on Saturdays - Nami added more
shows to the roster any of them hamster
related no but there is a demon Fox
guess it's a little better you stood up
you know nothing about that taro nothing
what are you people
time to sharpen your blonde hair and
bring out your inner demon now Renault
is fighting the good fly if you like
Dragonball Z but felt like it needed
more ninjas than Naruto might have been
more your speed
the show is another shown in franchise
about the hero's journey but focused on
an orphan boy with latent powers he
didn't know he had from a nine tailed
demon fox and he trains to hone his
abilities fighting stronger opponents
along the way
sound familiar mystic pizza okay yeah
Masashi Kishimoto was heavily influenced
by Dragonball even creating Naruto
loosely resembles Super Saiyan Goku's
appearance and sasuke resembling vegeta
all paralleling a similar frenemy
relationship while inspired by DB Naruto
was a little more grounded in its
concept focusing on shinobi in a war
turner world here the characters had to
hone their jutsu
weaving intricate hand signs in order to
properly execute a move this is where
Naruto found its foothold more so being
about strategy rather than who was
physically stronger so it's like avatar
only blonder it was more about whose
technique could beat one whose jutsu
could counter an attack could it work
from a different angle it became
intricate and fascinating like a game of
chess instead of just armwrestling also
Naruto actually had some pretty
effective storytelling that fans could
relate to
for example Naruto was an outcast and
Sasuke had a similar background in
Naruto though Sasuke is a lot more
respected simply because of their
differing Heritage's their stories are
all neatly woven into some political
intrigue the hypocrisy of the ninjas
governing world and blah blah blah if
that's not your thing
here's more fighting your
Oh Naruto had several great characters
and Rocklea was by far my favorite he
was quirky and strong-willed and had to
supplement his inability to use jutsu
with his raw martial arts skill I
thought that was so badass the fact he
looks like the Momo challenge it's also
enough to intimidate any enemy
all-in-all Naruto quickly became a
successor to the action junkie fans of
Dragon Ball Z the series roaster
popularity right as the Dragon Ball
franchise's initial run was coming to an
end
Dragon Ball super would become a thing
but until then Naruto had the action and
the characters to give us our show name
things demons living inside you is fine
are they but what happens when aliens
live inside you well I think we found
that out don't call the men in black
we got your alien Pokemon all set up in
big 10 alien force
Benjamin Kirby Tennyson gets an alien
watch device called an Omnitrix allowing
him to ship shapes into 10 different
alien heroes in Benton five years later
we get a darker and more grown-up
fifteen-year-old Ben invent an alien
force his Omnitrix has recalibrated
giving him access to more alien heroes
that are stronger and more powerful than
the og episodes with the help of his
cousin Gwen and his former nemesis Kevin
Ben is out to find his missing father
and fight the dnaliens Wow well this
sounds superior compared to the first
show this is inferior compared to the
first show course it is yeah though the
aliens may be stronger and more powerful
the writing animation and storylines
have taken a downgrade for sure I enjoy
alien force overall and out of all the
different spin-off series that came
after the original Ben 10 it is the best
but it does seem to lose a bit of what
made Ben 10 so much fun don't get me
wrong we wanted more than ten and we got
some great episodes with this updated
and more adult version it's just never
gonna quite capture the magic the
original Ben 10 had it's by no means a
bad show but it doesn't hold a candle to
the original
[Music]
but let's get back to anime with YuYu
Hakusho did you just sneeze backwards
everybody asks that
[Laughter]
they say finger pointing is rude well
with YuYu Hakusho it can save your life
created by OSHA he wrote oh gosh Jean
this was a very unique series in of
itself the story starts with a
delinquent high school student you skate
you are messy our main character ends up
dying right at the beginning of his
story trying to save a child's life from
an oncoming car short series 15 shorter
from here he's granted abilities by the
powers that be in the afterlife to stop
heinous crimes from demons and spirits
trying to take over the mortal world
Yusuke becomes what is called a spirit
detective solving crimes the authorities
couldn't it was like men in black but
with ghosts and the occult so more like
Ghostbusters Meets Chinatown
only less incest the Ghostbusters had a
lot of that well the concept was another
monster-of-the-week scenario it had a
unique film noir edge to its approach
the series saw some decent success in
the early 2000s getting a prime-time
spot on tsunamis block it was an
interesting idea executed uniquely with
a great style and characters to keep us
interested until the end he did start to
lose its unique touch trying to mimic
the explosive styles of other anime
action series but thankfully ended on a
more grounded note with Yusuke coming to
terms with his heritage and finding a
new family in the friends he's made
spoilers yeah family and friends are to
be valued I did not know that it loses
its roots once or twice but it gets back
on track near the end
oh let's talk about the Batman which
line the TV show which line the animated
one which one the one that's just okay
[Laughter]
another Batman in the belfry but this
one contains the word V in front of it
the Batman tries to change things up for
better or worse simply put this is
another passable animated Batman show
have we seen it before
more or less does it bring anything
extremely new to the table now the
animation is cool and seeing a younger
Batman made his villains for the first
time is fun but not really is it still a
good show that I recommend Oh back yeah
sure this series borrows a lot from what
we've seen before the character arcs are
all mostly the same with some slight
variations mostly due to other DC shows
running at the same time we do get a
large assortment of classic Batman
villains which is cool and overall of
solid lead designs show what is
interesting is that Robin doesn't appear
until season four because he was in Teen
Titans which was running until the
Batman started its fourth season we get
instead Batgirl as his sidekick up until
then other than that the characters that
we know and love are all there we only
get two series original characters that
aren't seen in other adaptations chief
angel Rojas and detective Ellen Yin
original that's alysom awesome
oh come on
that's scary how much they look alike
well maybe they're sisters
I think she's Asian I think you should
shut up the Batman doesn't take as many
chances as other Batman shows but it
doesn't do the exact same thing either
the characters do have a look that you
can easily identify as being from this
show unlike the other Batman
incarnations where they all look pretty
similar it's nothing groundbreaking but
it's just different enough to warrant
viewing
yeah but that show was what five seasons
I want to show that goes on for so long
it's like a tire fire no amount of water
could possibly put out one piece also
why would you want that
it's the Energizer Bunny of anime one
piece definitely knows how to keep going
and going and going one piece if you
like Dragonball but felt like it needed
more pirates have to come back to Dragon
Ball yes pilgrims in an unholy land
okay that's unfair to say but Eiichiro
Oda was also another manga creator
heavily influenced by Akira Toriyama
one piece is a treasure in of itself
garnering its own popularity to put
itself in the same league as Dragon Ball
and alike it's the story of Luffy an
orphan boy with strange powers who wants
to become the king of the Pirates by
becoming the strongest and finding the
highly coveted MacGuffin
I mean treasure known as one piece his
journey involves giants sea monsters and
animal people ghosts ghouls drag queens
and super-powered beings that utilize
the various powers from a food called
devil fruit sounds like if Monkey Island
was a drama having swallowed a devil
fruit himself one called the gum gum
fruit is that similar to ham hams I will
cut you oh you son of a bitch so it
turns him into a rubber human in the
same vein as mr. fantastic from the
Fantastic Four part of the fun of the
show is the world is larger than life
and super imaginative they travel to
various islands from ones in the sky to
once at the bottom of the very ocean
they sailed when Naruto accomplished in
detail and creative fights and
Dragonball Z did in its explosive action
one piece did for world building alas
hearing lies the double-edged sword of
Oda's riding the world was fully
detailed and fleshed out almost a little
too detailed the constant talking about
the world starts to bloat the story and
digress from the plot sometimes becoming
boring and hard to follow and I mean
episodes will be spent on
giving the background of a new character
something that could be easily summed up
in a flashback as of this review this
show has 20 seasons and nearly 900
episodes and they still haven't found
one piece it's like for every episode it
generates three more like a perpetual
anime episode machine in this house we
obey the laws of thermodynamics
interestingly tsunamis saved this show
for the US by putting Funimation's dub
on air when one piece is being localized
to the US its initial four kids dub was
a lackluster show at best with clumsy
translations and heavily unnecessary
edits an already abstract story was
becoming increasingly hard to follow
thankfully after four kids lost the
dubbing rights but omission picked it up
to do it justice just another anime -
nami helped out to keep going even if it
looks like there's no end in sight
speaking of knowing insight do you
remember when Star Wars was gonna end at
some point
no one's ever really gone the force is
strong with this one
so much so that many people like Star
Wars the Clone Wars even more than the
prequels talk about combining an insult
in a compliment did you like the
extended universe mists of solo and
rogue one yeah then listen up Oh No
well still listen up because this series
is awesome star wars the clone wars is
what happens when we keep everything
cannon but fix the prequel movies Anakin
fixed Padme fixed Jar Jar Binks okay you
know we can't have it all it's like
you're in death it's never gonna happen
the character design and development in
this series is off the charts Anakin is
what we always wanted angry but not
inherently evil not upfront at least
remember when obi-wan speaks about
Anakin and a new hope and it's like he
was the best star pilot in the galaxy
and a cunning warrior and wasn't good
Fred well we actually see that character
development in this show also the series
specific characters like ahsoka and
asajj ventress are so killer
figuratively and literally
while the Clone Wars is an awesome CG
series whose animation improves greatly
as each season goes by just Clone Wars
is a micro series with hand-drawn
animation and is just over two hours
long even with that short runtime though
this micro series is epic the music the
story the action the art style all
incredible also being directed by genndy
tartakovsky seriously can this guy do
any wrong this is an even awesomer
samurai jack with lightsabers yeah and
awesomer samurai jack with lightsabers
made in between star wars episodes 2 & 3
this was made to bridge the gap of time
for viewers and in my opinion is better
than all the prequels combined so yeah
if the Star Wars movies aren't doing it
for you anymore
don't think that they're your last hope
for there is another
[Music]
on September 20 a 2008 Cartoon Network
announced it would be canceling Toonami
due to low ratings for many this was the
end of an era though there would still
be anime and other more adult shows on
Cartoon Network it seemed the Gateway
that made us aware of so much great
content was finally being closed off so
many foreign imports that wouldn't have
gotten nearly as much attention or
exposure Oh a lot to what Toonami did
for them it opened our eyes to so many
shows so many adventures so many
characters that we would hold dear to
our hearts
whether for laughs tears dumpling or
gripping drama tsunami left a legacy of
programming that we would never forget
[Music]
but then one evening on April 1st this
played yeah ha ha ha Cartoon Network
once again ran their April Fool's prank
of playing the room only this time it
was a double bluff and got the results
of the test back definitely have April
Fool's Cartoon Network didn't plate the
room but instead played a sneak peek of
its return to Toonami apparently enough
people over the years have requested its
return and on May 26 2012 Toonami was
back its had changes since its return as
is to be expected but now a new
generation could be introduced to the
excitement and build up of getting ready
to watch something not 100% for adults
but not 100% for kids either
it was the stepping stone into great
stories and different styles that were
always seen in everyday media a mixture
of corniness intensity comedy drama
simplicity complexity and of course a
ton of action Toonami gave just the
right amount of edge that whether
introducing us to something old or
something new it always gave us
something epic and tons and tons of
young people out there couldn't have
been more thing
thanks for watching tanaami faithful and
remember if you want a really cool
channel go over to epic voice guys page
he's so funny and handsome and uh pay no
attention to the a big voice in the
booth
so critic it sounds like you finally
came around on Toonami
yeah you know what first I didn't get it
but after hearing you all talk about it
I finally realized the impact that it
actually had come on let's watch one
more Oh Holy Smoke sorry I'm late haha
oh whoa you guys done know you cannot be
done talking about tsunami you haven't
even talked about the biggest show they
ever had on Jackie Chan adventures okay
so Jackie Chan is this archaeologist
right and he has to travel around the
world and find of these talismans
there's 12 of them and they're based off
of the zodiac signs and then he's trying
to keep them away and out of the hands
of the evil people they're called the
dark hand they're evil they're working
for this demon his name is Shendu he's
the worst and he's also trapped in a
dragon statue because his regular form
is a dragon and he wants to get back to
his regular form Jackie Chan has to
fight all these bad guys Easter eggs of
his entire career throughout the show
it's incredible after each episodes
because these children that right in and
get to ask Jackie Chan questions and
then he answers them it's amazing and
then oh I guess it's just you and me
again Jade
you
and the Wonder Twins zan and jayna with
their space monkey Gleek
hey Doug Walker here Habitat for
Humanity is this week's charity Habitat
for Humanity partners with people in
communities all over the world to help
them build or improve a place they can
call home Habitat homeowners help build
their own homes alongside volunteers and
pay an affordable mortgage with your
support Habitat homeowners achieve the
strength stability and independence they
need to build a better life for
themselves and for their families
through their 2020 strategic plan
Habitat for Humanity will serve more
people than ever before for decent and
affordable housing their vision is to
see a world where everyone has a decent
place to live if you agree that
everybody has the right to live a life
where they can prosper and grow then
click on the link and help these good
people continue to build hope
you